welcome to cbs this morning and welcome
to both of you gail tony taking a friday
off
good to be here nice to see you all
right so it's been an incredibly
emotional
week as we all know but we wanted to
start this morning with something
really really cool as anthony mentioned
history was made a short time ago
at kennedy space center three two
one zero mission
and liftoff got exceeded
four astronauts are now on their way to
the international space station with
help from a
spacex falcon 9 rocket it has never
been done this way before mark strossman
witnessed the launch and he joins us now
mark we were all here in the studio
watching it as it happened
it's quite a day good morning a
spectacular
pre-dawn liftoff and light show and a
major milestone for spacebacks
the company reused both the first stage
booster and the space capsule
that flew on earlier missions it's done
that before with cargo but
never people until today
the astronauts were met with cheers on
their way to the launch pad this morning
they even got a send-off from spacex ceo
elon musk we can see the astronauts
inside the
crew access arm inclement weather
postponed the launch
yesterday but this morning endeavor
launches once
again the international crew which
includes two americans
launched on a mission that's the first
of its kind we have just passed through
max q
around two and a half minutes after
liftoff already traveling more than 4
thousand miles per hour
the reused first stage booster separated
roughly seven minutes after that
the crew entered orbit more than 125
miles above
earth where not long ago they had this
to say
we're a couple hours into the fight
making our second lap around the earth
musk said it's the dawn of a new era in
space exploration
we don't want to be one of those single
planet species we want to be a
multi-planet species
as for this mission nasa astronaut bob
benkin can vouch for the recycled
hardware
he flew in the same capsule to the space
station last year
this time it's his wife crew member
megan macarthur
they have a seven-year-old son theo what
does your son
think about all the unusual travel both
his parents do for work
he has had of course a long duration
exposure to all of this of course he
recently saw his father launch
and then stay on the international space
station for two months
now you know it's mom's turn and i'm
gonna be gone for six months and when he
talks about it he talks about well he's
going to go next
but first little theo and his father
will get up early tomorrow morning to
watch another magical moment
macarthur and her crew will dock to the
international space station
right after 5 a.m anthony mark
you know my parents traveled a lot but
not like that
that's really something mark thank you
so much
what an i just i'm thrilled by this i
have to say i love that a mom
is going into space and she's she left
son at home with dad
i just love the idea of that and kids
are back i mean when i was a kid buzz
aldrin and neil armstrong were like
heroes of mine and it's great to see
children
really into it now yeah sure is and i
hope he gets to i hope their son gets to
go to space that would be really neat
all right